the pandemic has devastated the
restaurant industry in the u.s
nearly 100 000 restaurants were forced
to close either permanently
or for the long term in the first six
months of the pandemic
that's according to the national
restaurant association and nearly six
million restaurant jobs were lost in
just march and april
nikki batiste shows us how one
family-run restaurant in new york city
was rescued from the brink by kindness
and community support here in downtown
new york city stands the gee whiz diner
almost thirty years ago peter penny oh
two created this cornerstone of the
community
the restaurant survived hurricane sandy
and 9 11
but shortly after the pandemic shut down
dining in the city
65 year old peter became a victim of
coveted 19.
after his passing i was just
interrupting a sense just stayed at home
just
didn't do anything well the only thing i
was thinking about was
maybe i should sell the place cut loss
move forward but when he came to check
on the diner two months after
his father's passing what he found
completely changed his mind
when i came here and i saw the whole
front door decorated with just cards
they were just writing the condolences
how much they missed my dad
it was just like
i was overwhelmed overwhelmed it was
very heartfelt i couldn't believe it i
relied on him
so much every morning i had a coffee
and he had a wisdom we talked small
things to big political things
and he was always there for 25 years
takashi nagaki came to the diner almost
daily
he says peter was the kind of man who
welcomed everyone
offering free food to the homeless and
senior citizens
so many people just will come and say
how much they miss them
share stories with me that even i didn't
know about that
how he will do one act just
to help someone because that was the
person he was
then came a simple indelible tribute to
his dad
someone welded peter pennier two on the
sidewalk in front of the diner
i was in awe and i'm like
that's a sign i said thank you dad that
was his sign to say keep it going
and you have no idea who did this no
still don't
for chris the outpouring of love gave
him the courage he needed to carry on
his father's legacy
this is his store we're going to keep
running it if the person who
welded your dad's name here is listening
and watching what would you like to say
to them
thank you so much
[Music]
you saved your wiz you pushed me forward
that little gesture gave me a lot of
strength
i thank you so much for cbs this morning
nikki batiste new york nikki boutique
should have told us we needed tissues
for that story
exactly that was amazing and you could
see how much it affected his son
and what the difference peter made to
people yeah
just the name of the diner the gee whiz
diner sounds so welcoming
it's an american story it's also a new
york store it's what it is it makes the
city
great and it will bounce back but you
know what guys whenever i hear stories
like that and people say who are we
yeah as americans i go that's who we are
right there right there thank you nikki